so so so so dass die wir sind ja hier
oben noch höhere objekt für die kürzlich
abholen seligmann grunde merkel tut in
kommen so wichtig überholen lassen
ja die habe ich mir selber geklaut und
gehen dann zeigt das wie jetzt da rein
kommt und dass man es merkt deswegen
sage ich und du weißt du doch wohl auch
ein gekommen er wurde dann zeig ich dir
weiter ich glaube so geht
halt nicht auf wieso ich hier könnte man
vielleicht den jonas nein gar nicht
nicht sehr von oben rein worden
ja gut ich werde es nicht noch einmal
geben die regionalen die auf der stelle
was will der denn wir sind nicht mehr
drin
die aber da hinten jetzt eigentlich
leichter grundsätzlich lasse ich bin
schon rein gekommen
man kann hier oben drauf da vorne kann
man auch halten
ich habe kommen müssen schwerer
beifahrer das gar nicht schaffen muss
sich in der luft und lass das mal
probieren und hier oben so söllner
ich glaube ich ahne ich habe schon
wieder zwei punkte bekommen euch mit dem
kruse kommt jetzt keine ahnung
doch japan im auto geht das immer das
wort die falsche warten
hier soll jetzt bitten
[Musik]
das wetter braucht dann muss aber noch
mit ihr hinten drauf dass ich jetzt hier
kommt gelang erhöht soll da einmal
allein schon sein deine ganze anzug
suchen mehr als einen punkt
du hast ja auch fast nicht an meine flip
flops wie noch weniger als seine
lackschuhe so so so so dass die gut weil
wir machen das jetzt so gar nicht aus ja
genau hier ist genau jetzt stellt das
ist richtig krasser jetzt erst achte
runtergefallen gefallen ein gewisses
absichtlich er hat nicht einfach
gewonnen
und später ich habe einige töte ich hab
ein getötet ich habe einen getötet aber
jetzt soll ich mich keiner mehr im weg
stehen wenn diese hier über diesen job
mein gott hinten kommen welche welt
kommen welche und ich hab fast kein
leben mehr junge bitte schnell ein alter
[Musik]
du wirst du hier abgebildet ich bin ich
bin draußen wo man gottes wirtschaftlich
harten checks ja wieso ich nicht und ich
finde einfach an steil nach oben
da stehen sogar noch drei anderen jetzt
ja ich weiß da ich war direkt daneben
muss der typ muss ihn richtig weit nach
oben geflogen jetzt bayern führte 1 0
durch ein tor von franck ribery gegen
aschau gegen gran schauwecker ich bin so
hoch höher geht es nicht aber
helikopters sind unter mir also ich bin
richtig weit oben an
ich sehe die komplette geht die armut
gerade nahezu höher geht es nicht mehr
geht es nicht doch noch gedacht das
freut mich echt durch die ja ich sehe
die komplette gt hier weiter höher geht
wirklich nicht
soll ich jetzt mal raus springen
oder versuchen mich mit dem jet zu
treffen
ich bin jetzt raus oh mein gott bei der
höchsten stelle ich raus gespielt und
mein gott oh mein gott mein gott ich der
ganzen diese ganzen gegen gott mein job
meine jet fällt da hinten irgendwo hin
jetzt alter wir sind jetzt erst mal
richtig lange in der luft bestimmt
oh mein gott ich versuche direkt wieder
damit der basis zu landen
wenn wir das sehe ich wieder die
militärbasis fallschirm habe ich ja
versuchen auch wieder die militärbasis
kommen wie man reinkommt weißt du jetzt
ja ich versuche so lange so zu bleiben
wie es eben geht
so dahin lassen red
diese merken es gleich oh mein gott nein
halt auch keins nicht gewusst hätte ich
mehr leben gehabt hätte ich das bestimmt
hingekriegt wichtiger nun bin ich um den
kopfhörer für den vertrieb solle weiter
hier rumpeln oder noch was anderes
scrollen
aber wie schafft man dazu sagen wer
glaub ich auch nicht geht geht ja auch
so ein passagierflugzeug zu läuft wo
bist du kannst mich abholen
na ja lass mal unter der brücke ist dass
man zum jahrmarkt wie könnte es uns ganz
viele sachen schreiben die wir eventuell
machen sollen also schreibt alles rein
sammelnde bank ausrauben
sollen wir uns helikoptern ihr können
auch noch mal so eine mission probieren
die wir letztes mal kläglich gescheitert
sind
wir können ja auch mal so eine seine
mission machen so eine richtige mission
nicht einfach so ein rennen weiß ja ja
genau ich meine machen ja kriegst du
möchte mal rainer da muss ich da auch
ich glaube ich ein land online-shops top
posten von rockstar erstellt missionen
die herstellung von method ein
gefährliches geschäft
das habe ich dann gemacht einen sammler
black country sind sicherheitsmängeln
und co2 emissionen piepegal er braucht
ein paar patriot suvs die man nicht zu
ihm zurück verfolgen kann
vier spieler da zwei drogenwelt
transport ist auch das anrennen
das ist auch was mit flugzeugen das ist
auch kacke laster haft
das können wir machen ich lade dich mal
ein
also wenn das geld jetzt irgendwie weil
leute nur einige wollen ja dass wir ne
scheiß machen einige wollen auch für
jobs machen und jetzt macht das 2 0
und einige wollen dass minecraft 2 0
durch mag jemand angreife stunden 1000
minute sind die gerade du musst dich
entscheiden muss man halt ruft mich an
glaube ich muss mich anrufen
ich konnte doch ich kann ich hinzufügen
ich habe sich eingeladen downloading
aber sollte gleich sowie schulden
genauso so
kenia ist unser ziel ist wie schwer kann
es einem schon fast ein bisschen über
geburten der grenze in der wüste zu
schaffen so schwer wie es ihm den
anderen teams gegeneinander stimmt ja
jetzt nicht mehr das bei mir egal
so ging zu ende ist gegen das design für
glaube ich so so vier gegen vier oder
sechs
wir kommen 13 wohnungen ich kann nicht
erwischen
ich musste mich den laster nehmen oder
was ist denn das die deutschen den
lastwagen
[Musik]
wie soll ich denn bitte ein kommt werden
können zu sparen
naja ich guck mir erst mal mein gott wie
kann nicht einfach so eine abkürzung
bei mir läuft einfach jonas wo bleibst
du denn du bist ja irgendwas wird dabei
die auf der karte angezeigt im ziel ein
roter dicker roter okay weil das der weg
von ihnen da steht das steht einfach
zerstört
syskoplan nicht sag mal wie weg hier
stehen als ob nicht nur in doha
a
vielleicht schon da bist
ich war richtig war sie gut besser kann
ich gar nicht fahren
nein ich bin im wasser stecken geblieben
das schaffst du dir das kann nicht sein
siehst du mir leid aber ich glaube ich
werde dich sehen wenn du willst mit
solchen verpackten fast allen sphären
kommst scheiße
dann ist es auf 6,5 kilometer und ich
frage hat so gut ich kann
erstmals sind zwei leben von dem ich bin
eben kollidiert die augen denn auch
gerade einen achse dorf ist so ein
großer roter ich bin ganz klein auf
einem grünen fahrrad lag ihr sehr gut
bittet mich nicht witzig jonas
machen den friedensvertrag
die halter ich weiß nicht wie das gehen
soll ich hab eine shotgun und fahre ich
gebe es nun mal keine tipps
david gegen goliath
eigentlich habe ich auch noch mitspieler
weißt du eigentlich hab ich auch noch
mitspieler die mich dann hast du das
gesehen
aber eigentlich habe ich auch noch
mitspieler weißt du wie die ich dann
irgendwie davon abhalten nicht zu
zerstören
aber irgendwie habe ich halt gerade
keine ja und ich habe glaube ich auch
noch mal auf mit die mir helfen und zwar
zwischen 11 ja natürlich das ist ja
nicht als wurden gesagt ja aber wenn du
ganz viele hast dann ist es besser für
mich besser wenn ganz viele leute dabei
sind als nicht also wenn du als einziger
ging nicht dann gerne kompliziert die
gab es nicht auch nicht ändere ich kann
das wollte hier auch eigentlich einen
tipp geben
ja ich das probiere ich auch schon daran
vielleicht kannst du dich umbringen oder
den truck allgemein ich dachte dass er
so eine geile aktion ist es eine mission
gespielt wo man so einen lkw holen
musste dann muss man den beladen und
dann wieder woanders hinbringen sosa
megageil aber das nicht einfach so
online weil das umfeld also das ist
jetzt nicht so ist man ganz einfach mal
ein falschfahrer ja ich glaub das ist
echter werk auf so einer welt rum fahren
wir wissen scheißegal
oder können sie das schreiben was wir
genau machen sollen schreibt jetzt haben
die kommentare was wir jetzt so hier so
anders machen sowas wie so die mission
sind ja auch glaube ich nicht für einen
stream ganz konzentriert ist aber ihr
werdet dann einfach mal sogar fahrt zu
einer plattform und springt darunter
oder unbedingt auf diesem weg ich falsch
habe einfach keine ahnung in gips
denn die luftigkeit
ja da sagt leider dauert bis es ankommt
aber natürlich schon wollen wir einfach
mal um zu mir aber auch nicht so
zufrieden
den winkel ich habe noch 2,5 kilometer
ich denke danach beenden wir dann auch
mal wieder diese vorne gehen
er ist heftig dass schon wieder ein
fluss zu gut aufgenommen haben so viel
scheiße hier also von mir aus können
auch noch eine folge aufnehmen
so habe ich die chance ist würde ich
jetzt seit gesprochen versuchstiere
erarbeitet nicht immer vor
das werden wir ganz doll wird zerstört
in sekunden hat sich gemäss und bin hat
sich die form eines bikes verändert
gezeigt
und so reihte der versucht zum vierten
mal bei dieser mission 800 meter
diese version sogar verdammt recht
machen wir wurde halten mal mit ein
bisschen missionen respekt ist es ist
einfach immer vor jetzt in den letzten
metern kommt es jetzt auf mpg auch bei
mal an wir sind zufällig direkt vor die
es pro jahr wenn ich es bestimmt passte
die ganze einem wert bis zum bild hinaus
ok go nicht dennoch dürften
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
auch keine gps auf jeden fall könne dann
nochmal jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen
kacke bauen was wir dann machen wir
hinfahren in denen nichts ist jetzt
übernehmen nochmal kreis und jetzt klick
auf freien modus manche witze merken wo
gibt es noch hier was weiß nicht rennen
haben wir schon mal zum hier gibt es
spannendes ihr wert gerade live dabei
wie ich papier gegessen habe aus
versehen kopieren da